hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es wieder ein leckeres rezept
für die kategorie was kommt heute heute
gibt es eine panne hat fleisch pfannen
und ich brauche dafür gar nicht mal so
viele zutaten
wir brauchen etwas olivenöl ein kilo
hackfleisch ich habe zehn rinder
hackfleisch 200 gramm geschälte zwiebeln
also dass geschälte gewicht sehen 2
knoblauchzehen 600 milliliter sahne
hier habe ich 20 gramm getrocknete
steinpilze und die habe ich bereits in
500 milliliter warmes wasser eingelegt
wer möchte nimmt noch zwei bis drei
chili eine bio zitrone 800 gramm panel
nudeln 1 bund petersilie und salz und
pfeffer ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal
die soße vorbereiten bei doodle rezepten
ist es immer ganz wichtig die soße
wartet auf die nudeln das heißt die
nudeln kommt dann erst ins nudelwasser
wenn die sauce schon fast fertig
erst nehme ich jetzt die zwiebeln dem
rad fahre doch die sally und im monat
warteten auf die sitzung genommen und
die schneide ich jetzt gemeinsam mit den
knoblauch sehen einfach in feine ringe
mich zu vielleicht was zu den pilzen
sagen getrocknete pilze genau wurde sie
gefunden hast weil der murat mit seinem
einkaufen gehen
ja ich muss immer fragen wie lange sich
nur tot die ganzen verkäuferin
letztmalig sechs verkäufer mikro und
alle wollten wir helfen wenn sie sich
kannten
ja ja und die pilze habe ich bei den
gewürzen gefunden komisch
also da gibt es die getrockneten pilze
und die sind auch ganz wichtig bei dem
rezept denn man muss der vorher
einweichen und 20 minuten stehen lassen
das habe ich jetzt wie gesagt schon
vorbereitet dass frau ist oder genau
dann hat man so richtig viel geschmack
in der flüssigkeit denn die benutzten
wir später direkt mit für die sauce mit
dem
einkaufszettel was meinst du meinst dass
du den einkaufszettel der nicht
ausgedruckt habe dort ausgepackt und
vergessen oder in verloren und damit
geschäftsführer gefragt ob er mich
anrufen kann ich mich von der
information angerufen wurde ein handy
akku war leer ich hab den einkauf stent
vergessen und muss seine luftbild von
allem von der information aus angerufen
genau der kleine murat hat seinen
einkauf schliffer gästen handys ist
leider akku leer als cool dass dem einen
ohr hatten weil du wahrscheinlich
auswendig neid ist schon ordentlich
gott sei dank endlich alles und wirklich
verloren auch ehrlich zu finden etwa
daheim fahren müssen und mit starken
farben beim einkaufen die lage jeden
morgen wenn sie mich sehen sich schon
ich war jetzt wegen nazi besteht denken
sie auch aus der kleinen heute wieder
vor gebe ich etwas olivenöl in die
pfanne
jetzt fiel erst öffnungen und jetzt
brate ich da das hackfleisch
portionsweise drin an
das hat vielleicht angebraten ist
nämlich raus ich habe übrigens auf 23
mal angebraten denn die panne ist nicht
so groß und so hat man einfach keine
gefahr dass es gleich wasser sieht also
man kann also auch richtig gut heiß
anbraten
deswegen immer kleine portionen und
jetzt nehme ich noch mal vier esslöffel
olivenöl wartet jetzt die zwiebeln und
den knoblauch würfel drin an oder
knoblauch schreiben tolle pilze wie sein
wenn wir zeit pilze benutzen erzählen
also ist echt super erlebnis hitze ok es
treffen die zwei schnecken im wald eine
der beiden ist total zuschreibt dem
gesicht fragt die eine warst du
angestellt sagt die andere
ich bin nicht vollgas durch den wald
schießt plötzlich einen pilze aus dem
boden
da habe ich nie mehr bremsen können der
c klasse ski stars aus dem mond ja so
geht's mit arbeitskollegen immer da wir
auch immer einen klaren bild keystone
erlischt die pilze kies sich jetzt ab
aber fangen die flüssigkeit auf die
brauchen wir gleich nochmal abtropfen
und sobald die zwiebeln und den
knoblauch schreiben glasig gedünstet
sind also etwa jetzt gebe ich wieder das
hackfleisch mit dazu
jetzt könnte die pilze leicht ausdrücken
mit den händen und die noch grob hacken
und vom teilnehmer ist es jetzt so dass
es nur die wahl verlief auch kocht das
heißt wenn ich gleich die soße angießen
dann kann ich auch die nudeln ins wasser
schmeißen hierzu nur grob durch hacken
dann kommen die mit in die soße
kurz durchrühren jetzt gehe ich da die
sa 03
und auch ein bisschen von der pilz
flüssigkeit
jetzt muss es aufkochen und etwa acht
bis zehn minuten einkochen und dann kann
ich immer mal wieder etwas flüssigkeit
nach gießen es gibt dem ganzen den
geschmack und den derzeit koche ich auch
die panel oder
ich kenne ich die soße auch mal salzen
und pfeffern und die chili und die
petersilie ich damit ganz zum schluss
mit davon
ich habe jetzt die nudeln abgegossen die
sauce ist jetzt auch fertig mit taktisch
noch die petersilie und sie ist klein
und dann kann ich weiß servieren
so war das ziemlich schnell das macht ja
die website schnell aber dennoch sicher
ich gehe jetzt nicht alle drei chilis
mit rein denn demokrat marx mit sorge
schaut
ich nehme es noch die bio zitrone davon
kommt nur so ein hauch mit in die soße
das lockert so ein bisschen die sahne
soße auf und der morath geht mir jetzt
eine ganz große schüssel zum servieren
bitteschön
da kommen jetzt erst mal die nudeln reis
und mit diesem jetzt schön bissfest dann
die soße drüber
diese schon riesenpot aber ehrlich wie
viele leute suchen sagt du jetzt deine
freunde also gibt es jetzt auch viel zu
essen oder du bist doch keine freunde
macht gewinne des 10
es ist mal das ist mal ne ich habe
übrigens noch von dieser von diesem ein
weißer noch ein bisschen was da gibt es
aber nicht weg ihr könnt es ja auch dann
am nächsten tag noch zum kochen fall
wenn dann ganz viel geschmack drin
jetzt kommen noch die petersilien stücke
und auch das ist jetzt cool da werden
sich richtig freuen jungs und chili und
die restlichen spiele gebe ich aber auf
die macht aber fein teller magst du mir
direkt einen schönen teller geben
natürlich die kann ständig probieren
probieren ich weiß ich so schauts
andauern
ich weiß ich muss ich so sagen dass ich
sagen könnte kabel haben ich mag dich
kenne ich mehr drauf also ich hab eben
schon probiert wirklich lecker richtig
leckere soße vor allem mit ganz wenigen
zutaten wirklich und ein ziemlich
schnelles rezept auf also von anfang bis
ende und zubereitung bis jetzt hat etwa
25 bis 30 minuten maximal gedauert und
klasse
das schreiben ist fleisch ist richtig
lecker ich finde dass angebraten hatte
in der pfarre zuerst richtig groß und
das ohne zu mir sehen die konsistenz ich
mag es möglich auch die zwiebel schmeckt
die pädo siege schmeckst du und die
pilze sind vereinzelt auch weil sie
jetzt auch lust auf dieses leckere
rezept bekommen habt geht auf - blog.de
das stets normal und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachkochen
ich freue mich hier auf und mache hier
die männerrunde bereit ja aber ich
glaube ich sagen müssen sie keine pilze
sondern wird keiner merken ja aber ein
richtig tolles kantstraße dank liebe
kinder mit vollem mund spricht
wir stecken da haben wir essen alles mio
alles strecken